hi I'm Tan France from Queer Eye and I'm with @PoutGena
and here are my Netflix IX
is that what it's called
- yes - great
who of the fab five makes it
hardest for you when you're filming is
-so easy Jonathan Van Ness
he is a nightmare, you are a nightmare
that boy loves me way too
hard
even my husband doesn't love me as much
as his boy does he cannot stop being on
me at all times we are trying to shoot the
scene and he is there so desperately
just trying to but I'm like what are you
doing get off me like I'm trying to ask
this person questions they've never met us
before we are in their home and he's
literally climbing me he loves me too
hard
that's really sweet
shut up no it's not
*laughing*
you try living with that everyday I love you but it's a lot
so I want to talk to you about your love of Nando's
you spoke about that before talk
me through your order
ok, super simple if you have not tried this I need
you to try it if you don't eat meat then definitely don't
okay chicken livers medium
- mmm you've lost me
no stop no stop listen hey hey
listen to this I
always thought that livers were
disgusting however try it once at
Nando's and you will never go back
shut up so you have to ask for the saucy
otherwise it's not as good excuse me
whilst I belch belch
-it's the chicken livers
it's got me really excited, I belch when I'm giddy
but so then I also get the chicken in pita, medium with cheese and lettuce
-absolutely
peri peri chips not regular chips that seasoning is just *kiss sound*
gonna get a litte bit more serious now, who is your biggest inspiration
I don't know why this person came to mind
but I'm gonna say it 'cos that clearly
means something to me Michelle Obama
-*gasp* yes
I can't think of anyone more inspirational right now
-Michelle call me I've been trying to email you no reply
do you know what's nuts, I didn't say Barack. Barack I
have nothing but respect for you
however
-it's all about Michelle
-it's Michelle!
-the boots you see them boots
-oh my god of course I saw the boots she was iconic
picture this you're stuck on a desert island right you
can only take three British food items
you're  gonna judge me
-  I'm really trying not after chicken livers
Greggs cheese and onion pastie
*laughing*
Shut up!
- BASIC!
I know. Greggs cheese and onion pastie Gena you need to back up
-not even the meat one
-back up get her a cheese an onion pastie
-alright chicken liver boy
it's going to change your life. Ok pastie from Greggs. Walkers prawn cocktail crisps
-I'm with you
Finally, Bounty. I don't know who does it Cadbury or whoever but Bounty I love a Bounty
-ok no I like that. You brought it back.
no judgments
a question that is asked a lot is how do you figure out your own style
-the best advice I can give you is
this find somebody who is your style
inspo your style hero let's say for
example I was a dude here in England I
was my age I was into sport I would
choose David Beckham this is an obvious
one but David Beckham he dresses wicked
I would think of him every time I shop
so when I go shopping I would think
would he buy this I know we wouldn't
shop at the same places he's got a lot
more money than me clearly
there are cheaper options you can get of the clothes he wears so every time I go
shopping I would think what he wear this
if the answer's no don't buy it. It's a really good jumping off point.
Do you have a British hero or favourite Brit
it's so basic I know but I'm obsessed with Adele
-oh no that's fair that is really really fair
no she's not basic oh my
gosh Adele if you ever see this or hear this and are offended by that I mean
just because everybody loves you of
course everybody loves you. She
seems so incredibly genuine her talent
is incredible just the best
- do you have a favourite Adele song? This is just me asking for me
know I love that oh my god I could talk
about Adele for the next two hours
if you really want okay I'm gonna do this okay
because I can't do her dirty like this
by picking one. From 19 Hometown Glory
- okay
from 21 Someone Like You without a doubt
Oh or Don't You Remember
- oh yeah that is a beautiful song
okay two from that one
can't stick with the rules. From 25 I've
also got two miss you or missing you all
it might even be called I miss you something
miss you
second one is ummm. What's the name of it? All I...
(off screen) All I ask
Yes All I Ask
- a budding Adele fan
Thank you  we won't acknowledge who it is because this person will never be seen
on this episode
but there's a wonderful homosexual man who is also clearly an Adele fan and rightly so. All I Ask
Aside from Queer Eye what is your favourite Netflix show?
Wild Wild Country
- oh my gosh fantastic
because Ma Anand Sheela is the most incredible character ever. Don't get me wrong
she's batshit crazy like bitch you
batshit crazy but she achieved so much
she was 26 what was I doing at
26 not doing that what were you doing at 26 probably
not building a city like that is insane
so which is your favorite queer episode
So, which is your favourite Queer Eye episode
before I answer that what's your
favorite episode
- okay I don't remember the
name of the lady
- that's fine, Mama Tammy then
Yes yes yes yes with the church
you say it's a lady it's Mama Tammy. Ok
that is also my favorite
that moment where she apologised to her
son "Mama didn't that love you
unconditionally when she should have and Mama needs to apologise for that
people who are in the LGBTQ community
well anybody who is had to have a
conversation with a parent saying I'm
different I'm different to what you had
hoped I was going to be has experienced
that with their family member and it was
heartbreaking to sit through that and
she just is one of the most genuinely
wonderful people I've ever met in my life, really. Are you getting emotional?
- I'm just remembering it
I could feel you were getting emotional. Do not cry. I'm not the one who does well with that. Karamo isn't here to help.I'm just going to be like here here you're going to be alright.
If you were to add a sixth member
- oh say no more I've got it
thank you. There is so you guys up there I want to
tell you about this very special person
that I've met her name is Gena her
Instagram is PoutGena it's Gena
with an e and she needs to be the fab
six. Netflix execs you know who you are
Jenn Levvy, Ted Sarandos there's a
girl called Gena she is a highly skilled
and as you can see we bounce up each
other perfectly she fits right in
we need more colour on the show too
- please keep this in
*laughing*
Keep this in
ok are we good?
- we need to do an outro though
(off camera) no i think the outro is like cast Gena and then we cut
- oh yeah yeah yeah. great we got it
Hahaha I'm gonna be rich
*laughing*
(off camera) also don't think for a second I'm cutting "there's a homosexual off camera"
- of course, if you don't keep that in I'm going to be fuming